c'est un témoignage d'un ami à toi un
ami à moi tu es sûr femme que vous avez
eu en commun regardant ces images je
suis mcgill voilà je suis un bon copain
d'elie semoun que je trouve très drôle
et très sympathique mais il a un petit
défaut c'est que il est très séducteur
alors je sais qu'il n'a pas le physique
du séducteur dans émard il a plutôt le
physique d'un gars comptable dans la
cour de récré mais voilà donc il est ou
n'est il est très séducteur et une
anecdote c'est que un jour je m'étais
embrouiller moins que ma main et je
l'avais dit et on était vraiment froid
et tout ça et je sais que ces jours là
ce petit coquinou des vifs et moules bas
il avait commencé à tchater avec elle
sur instagram bas donc voilà je balance
ça rassure moyens et je voulais te dire
aussi une chose lycées c'est pas grave
je n'en veux pas on est tous les mêmes
mais j'ai des photos de toi torse nu et
ben faudrait pas que j'ai mon paulo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur
je vais vous dire je n'ai une chaudière
à damas et au togo
d'abord je ne sais même soit boubli voit
la base
apparemment il sait pas qui tu sais pas
qui suit non évidemment c'est faux
qu'est ce qu'on ferait pas pour passer à
la télé c'est vrai que elie par free
prend émeuvent des autres mais c'est de
bonne guerre
elle lui aussi suit prendre ta meuf on
embrasse françois hollande qui ne
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
devrait finir les règles j'ai
l'impression ouais que kev adams way est
drôle et drôle qui fait drôle voilà la
même je sais pas ultime journée avec ou